Amigos, es un hecho. China está de moda.
La influencia del régimen de Pekín en el
mundo nunca ha sido tan grande como ahora,
ni tampoco la fama y la presencia de China
en los medios de comunicación de todo el
planeta.
Y, ¿Sabéis? El responsable de todo esto
es este hombre.
(Xi Jinping se ha convertido en el presidente
de China que más poder ha acumulado desde
la caída de Mao Zedong.
Llegó al poder en 2013 con dos grandes promesas:
ampliar el poder y la influencia de China
en el mundo, por un lado, y consolidar el
poder político del partido comunista por
otro.
De esta forma, el presidente chino buscar
terminar con esa idea tan extendida de que
el desarrollo económico va seguido siempre
de transiciones políticas y procesos democráticos.)
Pero amigos, para conseguir sus metas y de
paso consolidar su poder,  Xi Jinping tiene
antes que sacarse dos grandes piedras del
zapato, dos piedras que percibe como una toda
una amenaza a la cohesión y a la identidad
nacional de China: Taiwán y Hong Kong.
Y precisamente de este último protagonista,
de Hong Kong, de quien vamos a hablaros en
este vídeo.
(Hong Kong está viviendo las que ya son las
mayores protestas civiles desde el fin de
la colonización británica, y ya van camino
de convertirse también las más largas.
¿El detonante? Tiene nombre y apellido: la
Ley de Extradición.
Veréis, propuesta por la Jefa Ejecutiva de
Hong Kong, Carrie Lam, siguiendo los deseos
de Pekín, esta Ley permitiría extraditar
a ciudadanos hongkongeses para ser juzgados
y en su caso encarcelados en la china continental.Es decir, esta propuesta de ley venía a reconocer
la validez de los tribunales controlados por el Partido Comunista Chino.
Y aunque finalmente tras la presión de los manifestantes la propuesta de ley ha sido retirada,
es una clara muestra de como empiezan a funcionar las cosas en Hong Kong.
Pero amigos, ¿Por qué ha sido esta propuesta
en concreto la que ha hecho reventar la paciencia
en Hong Kong? ¿Qué trascendencia tiene más
allá de las de la propia Ley? ¿Estamos asistiendo
acaso a un punto de inflexión histórico
en la relación entre la ex-colonia y China?
Atentos.
(LA LEY DE EXTRADICIÓN, LA GOTA QUE COLMA
EL VASO)
Así es amigos. Lo de la Ley de Extradición
no es ni más ni menos que la gota que ha
colmado el vaso.
Porque… No, no penséis que todo esto ha
empezado aquí, ni muchísimo menos…
Las injerencias de Pekín en la política
de Hong Kong y la proposición por parte de
las autoridades Hongkonesas de leyes pro-Chinas
que en realidad emanan del propio régimen
continental, del propio régimen chino, han
sido algo prácticamente constante desde la
transferencia de Hong Kong del Reino Unido
a China en 1997.
¿Queréis algún ejemplo? Fijaos.
(En 2003, tan solo 6 años después del traspaso
a China, el ejecutivo hongkonés propuso la
llamada Ley de Seguridad Nacional, que buscaba
prohibir y castigar a los movimientos independentistas.
Pekín buscaba, y digo buscaba porque la Ley
se canceló, blindar su soberanía sobre el
territorio y pisotear a la oposición.
Sin embargo no contaba con un pequeño escollo,
China se topó con la oposición feroz de
la ciudadanía hongkonesa que se lanzó a
las calles las dando lugar a las mayores protestas
de la historia en Hong Kong…
Hasta ahora.)
Sí, hasta ahora, porque las protestas
de este año 2019 ya han superado con creces
a las de 2003. Y la verdad es que sobran motivos.
Fijaos.
Imagina que vives en un territorio con un
sistema económico independiente, una justicia
garantista y una sociedad con un montón libertades
como, por supuesto, el acceso libre a internet
y a las redes sociales.
Y, de repente, un régimen dictatorial con
el que no te sientes nada, pero que nada identificado,
un régimen donde no existen ninguno de estos
derechos y libertades y dónde la justicia
está controlada por el partido único, pretende
imponer una Ley que permita que tú mismo
puedas ser extraditado para ser juzgado bajo
ese régimen y sus condiciones, ¿Qué harías entonces?
El descontento y la rabia parecen más que
justificados, ¿no creéis? Al fin y al cabo
la ley de extradición, aunque aparentemente
dejara fuera las acusaciones políticas, suponía
de facto el fin del modelo y la autonomía
de Hong Kong.
Porque claro…
[Vamos a ver, No me digáis que os cuesta
imaginaros a un tribunal chino pidiendo la
extradición de un disidente o un opositor
político de Hong Kong por cualquier otro
motivo. ¿A que no?]
(La Ley de Extradición es la sentencia de
muerte para Hong Kong, dice el librero exiliado
Lam Wing-kee. Hong Kong Free Press)
“Pekín usará esta ley para controlar Hong
Kong completamente. La libertad de expresión
se perderá. En el pasado, el régimen secuestró
a sus críticos, como yo, ilegalmente. Con
esta Ley, ellos abducirán a sus críticos
legalmente.”
Pues bien, el caso es que el descontento en
es tan grande que según un reciente estudio
del Programa de Opinión Pública de la Universidad
de Hong Kong nunca antes el rechazo a China
había sido tan grande entre los ciudadanos
hongkoneses como lo es ahora.
Pero… eso no es todo. Lo peor es la sensación
general que existe de que el ejecutivo hongkoneses
responde a los intereses de China y no a los
de sus propios ciudadanos.
Y eso es un problema en un territorio donde
los ciudadanos no pueden cambiar las cosas
porque lo cierto es que la democracia no existe.
En Hong Kong no hay sufragio universal y el
jefe del ejecutivo, del gobierno, se propone
desde Pekín.
Vamos a ver, en un país normal, democrático
y libre, si un gobernante lo hace mal, gobierna
en contra de los intereses del pueblo o se
descubre que favorece a otros intereses, la
gente le deja de votar a él o su partido
y pueden deshacer lo que no te gusta.
Sin embargo esto aquí no es una posibilidad.
Tras el traspaso a China, el sistema político
se ha convertido en algo muy pero que muy
parecido a un régimen corporativista que
gobierna para los intereses de dos poderosas
manos:
la mano de hierro china por un lado y la mano
del dinero de los grandes empresarios favorables
a Pekín por otro; especialmente de los grandes
jerarcas del mundo inmobiliario que han logrado
formar todo un oligopolio dónde Hong Kong
no es más que un mercado cautivo a su servicio.
¿Sorprendido? Pues… no deberías.
De hecho el sistema político hongkonés alimenta
y mucho este modelo.
(En Hong Kong, el Jefe del Ejecutivo - el
líder del gobierno -es elegido mediante sufragio
censitario por los miembros del Comité de
Elección, que cuenta con unas 1.200 personas.
Pero… ¿Y quién elige a estas 1.200 representantes?
Pues para ser sinceros es más fácil empezar
contando quienes no votan: los ciudadanos.
Hablamos de un sistema muy complicado en el
que participan organizaciones sectoriales,
líderes religiosos, líderes empresariales,
sindicatos e incluso empresas.
Todo orquestado para refrendar el poder de
China.)
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en lo que ocurre con
el sector de la agricultura, tradicionalmente
afín a Pekín. A pesar de suponer tan solo
el 0,1% de la economía hongkonesa los agricultores
tienen más peso en el Comité de Elección
que sectores mucho, muchísimo más importantes
como, por ejemplo, el sector financiero.
Muy democrático como veis no parece, ¿verdad?
Pues así, con todo.
De hecho la falta de democracia es el verdadero
motivo de las protestas actuales y también
de muchas de las protestas pasadas. Y es que,
veréis a pesar de no existir técnicamente
la democracia, Hong Kong es y ha sido durante
décadas un epicentro regional de activismo
político y la disidencia contra Pekín.
Y La Ley de Extradición pues tenía como consecuencia de facto
terminar con todas esas libertades.
Si lo pensais, eso es lo más dramático del
caso. En Hong Kong no es que estemos ya ante
una dictadura queriendo salirse con la suya
sino que estamos presenciando como personas
acostumbradas a vivir en libertad ven día
a día cómo están perdiendo toda esa libertad.
Y esto es lo que explica lo que viene a continuación,
atentos.
(LA TRIPLE LIBERTAD, CUESTA ABAJO Y SIN FRENOS)
Así es amigos, en Hong Kong las tres libertades
están en caída libre y sin frenos.
La libertad económica, la individual y la
política, las tres, han empeorado desde que
China se hizo cargo del territorio en 1997.
Y eso, eso algo que tiene consecuencias a
todos los niveles. Especialmente en un lugar
que ha sido tradicionalmente conocido por
su escrupuloso respeto a la seguridad jurídica
y por la estabilidad institucional.
Porque eso es lo que explica que alrededor
de 1.500 empresas multinacionales tengan su
sede asiática en Hong Kong.
Sin embargo amigos, ahora todo esto puede
terminar mal. No solo en el terreno político,
sino también en el terreno económico.
Las continuas injerencias de Chinas se están
traduciendo en muchos casos en graves, gravísimas
violaciones de la seguridad jurídica de las
empresas.
En el terreno económico, China ha incrementado
sus chantajes a empresas privadas para que
mantengan una postura crítica con cualquier
movimiento opositor a Pekín. Ya sabéis,
si no quieren tener problemas para permanecer
en el gran mercado chino.
Es lo que ha ocurrido, por ejemplo, con la
aerolínea hongkonesa Cathay Pacific, que
ha sufrido las consecuencias de no ser “crítica”
durante las protestas en contra de la Ley
de Extradición.
De no ser crítica y de no controlar suficientemente
las expresiones políticas de sus trabajadores.
(Cathay Pacific sustituye a su director ejecutivo
por el aumento de las presiones de China.
Financial Times)
(El personal de Cathay Pacific habla de clima
del miedo. BBC)
(Los empleados de Cathay Pacific dicen que
temen perder sus trabajos si expresan apoyo
a los manifestantes pro-democracia en Hong
Kong. Algunos están considerando llevar móviles
de señuelo en caso de que sus teléfonos
sean chequeados al llegar a la China continental.)
Pero no, no penséis que se acaba aquí.
Amigos, la represión en el terreno empresarial,
a los sectores productivos, está llegando
incluso a casos de boicots organizados por
el propio gobierno chino a través de redes
sociales.
Y no se salva nadie, ni siquiera el té de
burbujas.
(La batalla del té de burbujas: Las marcas
taiwanesas se enfrentan al boicot en la China
continental por sus gestos sobre Hong Kong.
Reuters)
Lo peor de todo es que no estamos hablando
de pequeños casos aislados.
En absoluto.
(Xi Jinping sabe que dirige un país con uno
de los mercados más deseados para toda empresa
que se precie. Una población abrumadoramente
enorme, una clase media cada vez mayor y un
poder de consumo a niveles ya exorbitantes.
Estar en China es estar cerca del éxito,
y Xi sabe que esta es una de sus grandes bazas
para presionar políticamente utilizando el
comercio y el sector empresarial.)
Y eso, eso evidentemente no es algo que tranquilice
a ninguna compañía. Un traspiés… y….
Además, ¿cómo diantres vas a controlar
a tus empleados? ¿Cómo vas a limitar su
libertad de expresión? ¿Cómo vas a atraer
talento con semejantes condiciones?
En fin, Se empieza con el té de burbujas,
y se acaba con toda empresa que no haga lo
que a China le plazca, y claro, esto no sólo
es algo reprobable sino también irresponsable.
Esta actitud de China, junto a la protección
a los oligarcas locales y el sometimiento
del gobierno local están terminando con la
prosperidad de Hong Kong. Los hongkoneses
sienten que están perdiendo no solo sus libertades
políticas sino que también está en riesgo
su propio bienestar económico.
Porque si Hong Kong pierde su independencia,
su seguridad jurídica y su neutralidad,
¿Qué diantres le queda?
Amigos, lo peor es que Hong Kong
puede que simple y llanamente ya haya dejado
de ser Hong Kong.
Seguro que ahora entendéis mejor el porqué
de las protestas y porque están durando tanto.
La sociedad hongkonesa siente que está ante
una de sus últimas posibilidades de resistir.
Que es ahora o nunca.
Pero si queréis saber por qué a Xi Jinping
le interesa tanto Hong Kong, y por qué a
pesar de todo China aún necesita a esta pequeño
territorio , estad muy atentos porque se avecinan
más vídeos sobre Hong Kong en los que os
explicaremos esta y muchas más cosas.